[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like a symphony of manipulating and
spinning and flipping the cards in your
hands it's like each move inspires the
next and you're not even thinking about
it
the cards are dancing between the hands
they're spinning around they're flipping
over they're doing things you wouldn't
even expect them to be doing it's just
so surprising almost magical
[Music]
for as long as I can remember we've
always done things in tandem together we
both got into magic around the age of 12
we would go to the library and check out
books by diver nin guy Hollingworth just
seeing the illustrations we're like wow
we can do this with playing cards when
we started practicing cardistry
it wasn't a thing it has its roots in
magic it comes from card magicians who
would use what is called the card
flourish and these were used to
accentuate certain moments in a magic
trick so we took that and just ran with
it we were the first to embrace it and
really focus on it and practice it as
its own thing and promote it as its own
thing
[Music]
cardistry is very much like
skateboarding
you know we practice these tricks until
we have them down perfect you know we
see other tricks and we're like oh we
got to learn that you have 52 playing
cards and the possibilities to to
maneuver those around are endless you
can hold the deck of cards in your hand
and it's one solid block now imagine
lifting up another block so now you have
two well what can you do with those two
blocks in your hands well you can create
more blocks and we call those packets
and you can start maneuvering and
spinning and flipping those packets
between your fingers it's hard like it
takes a lot of dexterity it's all
practiced it's all rehearsed and when
you're truly a master and you can just
start doing things on the fly and you
don't even have to think about it
[Music]
what kids are doing today with cards is
mind-blowing if you would have told me
that when I was 14 years old I would
have been like that's the coolest thing
I had no idea it could even be this big
the ultimate goal would be to get people
to almost put cardistry first when they
see a deck of playing cards you know
it's no longer for games it's no longer
for gambling it's Carter Street usually
people are really confused when I tell
them what I do I'd tell them like yeah
you own a fingerboard company like those
tech tax used to get in some like you
have a professional
[Music]
skateboarding makes me feel awesome it
doesn't get boring it's always a
challenge there's no rules finger
boarding and skateboarding both have
that
[Music]
I started fingerboarding in 4th grade I
had a lot of fun playing with the tech
decks and then I wanted to kind of
improve them a lot of times the screws
would come out so I'd glue them in and
just start modifying things like that
and I just realized I could make them
better and better a lot of kids wanted
to buy them so I kind of put a name on
it and it grew into this huge business
over time there's hundreds of thousands
of people out there that are into this
we are at the flat-faced rendezvous
location in Dracut Massachusetts and
it's pretty much a big building filled
with fingerboard parks and I do huge
events here where kids fly in from all
over the place to come and fingerboard
together when you go into a contest
that's crazy because there's stadium
seating and there's everyone looking at
you and lighting and cameras my first
few contests I got a crazy adrenaline
rush like you don't even remember the
thing after you do your run
I don't do any warm-ups or exercises
with my hands for fingerboarding
apparently some people do calisthenics
the rules are pretty much you want to
use two fingers you'll have maybe 30
seconds or a minute or so and you just
do a run and there will be a whole bunch
of judges they'll judge you on
consistency style the tricks you do it's
like really high pressure you can't even
really put it into words it's a crazy
kind of feeling and atmosphere when so
many people get together from all over
the world all over the country and some
of them it's like a really really big
deal to them like that's the only thing
they wanted to do all year it just makes
me super happy because I can barely
believe that I'm the reason they're
there like because of something that I
setup and that I'm doing
my job is actually 24 hours a day to
take care of my hands I'm definitely
very cautious with my hands I'm mark
careful more delicate with my movements
I get manicures fairly frequently
I don't do myself my name is Ellen
Surratt Susan Schell Tom Nico and I am a
hand model
I got noticed as a hand model after I
was featured in a jewelry shoot for a
magazine at the jewelry company I was
working at one day I was on a commercial
shooting a central park and they picked
me to do all the hand shots because the
hand model never showed up
probably most of us fall into it by
action I'm always in these upside-down
positions and having to have the
director on top of me or underneath me
you're being asked to do the most
natural things in the most of natural
ways sometimes I am in weird positions
for my oddest hand shoot I had to
pretend to chop a live human placenta I
had to do this one thing where I had to
be on Howard Stern's kind of naked body
he says to me look we're gonna try
something different I want you to stick
your thumb in the girl's mouth I've been
a hand model around 19 years it's been
great I've been very lucky I feel like
I'm gonna do this Psalm 90 my hands are
gonna look great and I love doing it and
you always need a hand that looks really
good
[Music]
your hands are really dexterous things
we use them everyday for all sorts of
tasks to make the best use we possibly
can of that is to build a puppet around
the hand so knuckles become knees or
elbows at the end of the day it's all
the illusion of movement my name is
Barnaby Dixon I'm a puppeteer alright
I'm 26 years old and I started making
puppets two years ago this is dab chick
this is the first puppet I ever made
this is Manu and it takes two hands to
operate this puppet and this is the
dinosaur I think this is the most
expressive puppet that I have I make
them in my room really each of these
puppets represents maybe two months work
and this is a process that's driven
completely by trial and error
the materials to make these puppets I
usually can just get them online raw
bits of metal or plumber's epoxy just
things like that really hey listen here
I made the puppets rigidly with the
purpose to create video content on
YouTube so check this out most weeks
I'll take dab check out for an outing
where I'll film it ah the great British
seaside software - sand oh joy of joys I
always do try and make them funny the
proud URI of the waves thundering -
airport I do get self-conscious about
having the puppets out and about some
people just think I'm an adult playing
with a toy people kind of don't know
what to think of it who knows maybe
Barnaby
hello so recently I was on a German
talent show that was about puppets it
was called dip upin stars
and I ended up winning this it was very
validating and so I think yeah a lot of
people would think is quite a weird
thing for a 26 year old to be in his
bedroom making puppets but it's working
out for me so ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I perform on stage I'm in my own
world the only thing going through my
head is that nothing else exists what
the trick I'm doing in that current
moment the yo-yo flings up in the air
goes under my leg it's being bounced
back and forth between the strings with
being sideways horizontally the way I
express myself on stage comes out and I
love that feeling where you could kind
of be free when I'm not on stage I'm a
graphic designer
living in Los Angeles most of the year
I'm just like any typical recent grad
trying to figure out what to do with
their life but come summer I'm preparing
to be the best yo-yo performer at the
world yo-yo contest my name is Ben Conde
I am a professional yo-yo player and I'm
ranked number one in North America and
the offstring division I think people
think yo-yos are incredibly simple but
it's gone a long way since being a toy
that goes up and down and now there's
all these new elements to it many people
don't know there are five styles of
yo-yo there's one handed yo-yo there's
two handed responsive yo-yo two handed
unresponsive yo-yo counterweight yo-yo
and off string yo-yo which is what I
specialize in it's riskier it's the
riskiest Division in my opinion because
of the fact that it can fall off the
string for the past 19 years I've been
working on yo-yo tricks trying to figure
out what tricks to do that's half the
battle
[Music]
because you're performing those tricks
to music one of the hardest parts is
telling a story through your music
giving the right energy and work on
making something flow it's a lot of hard
work that you put into it in any split
second of losing focus it seems like a
whole years of work goes the weight I
have to prove that I'm not gonna waste
the audience's time and for people to
respond positively towards it that I
like can't thank the sport no I started
playing yo-yo when I was four years old
and it's something I care about it's not
something I do for money
like it's a toy it's a toy at simplest
form and I just happen to be competing
with it for a really long time and
spending a lot of time learning in the
end it's something that makes me feel
comfortable
it keeps me youthful it reminds me of
what I would be playing with as a kid
[Music]
[Music]